[Music]
okay time to review amd's new radon RX
970 X1 you know what my legs are a bit
sore today probably all that ladder
climbing I did yesterday so I think when
to go sit down for this
one that's better isn't it bit more
comfortable now a lot has been said
about the 970 XT so much so that it kind
of feels like we've already reviewed it
but today we've relied on nothing more
than leaks and first part benchmarks and
neither of which are typically that
reliable so today finally we are taking
a very in-depth look at the 970 XT to
see what it's all about today's sponsor
spot is brought to you by thermal
Grizzly and the new Jena high
performance thermal paste Jena offers
extreme long-term stability combined
with outstanding thermal connectivity
and this has been achieved through a
specially engineered silicon oil
combined with aluminium micro particles
and zinc oxide nanop particles of
various shapes durut is is n
electrically conductive and won't Harden
over time for best performance you'll
want to apply a very thin layer and to
help with this included is the TG
spatula Pro the spatula revised design
allows for increased pressure during
application making it easy to spread a
thin even layer of durena so for more
information please check the link in the
video
description but before we jump into the
Benchmark data I'll quickly go over what
the 970 series is there are two models
the standard 9070 which is a bin or cut
down version of the 9070 XT both are
based on the same 357 Square mm die the
9070 XT packs
4,096 cores whereas the 970s core count
has been reduced by 133% to
3,584 cores it's also said to operate
the cores at 270 MHz so a 14% reduction
when compared to the XT version though
the actual core clock speeds will differ
underload as the memory subsystem it's
identical for both models so 16 GB of 20
GB per second gddr6 memory on a 256bit
wide memory bus resulting in a bandwidth
of 640 GB per second now all this means
is the 9070 series should be very
economical to produce given the D size
is similar to that of the 7800 XT and
the memory subsystem is also the same
AMD managed to sell that part for 500 $
us or less so they should be making a
decent amount of money on even the cut
down 970 silicon which has been given an
MSRP of $550 us while the full-blown 970
XT is set to cost $600 us the matchup on
paper between the oldest 7900 XT and the
9070 XT is quite interesting the 9070 XT
packs 24% fuel CES the die size has been
reduced by 33% the cash capacity it has
also been reduced This Time by 20%
there's 20% less vram and the memory
bandwidth has also been slashed by 20%
yet it is meant to deliver similar or
better performance so that's going to be
very interesting to see now on hand for
testing I have a number of 9070 XT
graphics cards I will be reviewing the
9070 in tomorrow's video so the focus
for today will be on the 9070 XT and all
of our Benchmark results are based on
the sapphire pel model but along on with
the pure I also have the Nitro plus XFX
Mercury Asus tough gaming and azrock
taiichi when placed under load we saw
Hotpot GPU temperatures range from as
low as 75° with the XFX Mercury to as
high as 87° which quite shockingly was
seen with the Nitro plus that's
particularly odd given the pure maxed
out at
81° the Asus tough gaming ran cool at
80° while the azck taiichi hit 8 5°
still given that this is a hot spot
temperature all models did run very cool
the gddr6 memory operated at 85° on the
Asus and XFX models while the rest run
at 90° then for the GPU vrm temperatures
we have quite a large range the azrock
taii and Sapphire Nitro plus both peaked
at over 80° while the P reached 79 de
then we have the XFX Mercury and Asus
tough gaming both of which kept their
vrm comfort below
70° now when it came to operating volume
the azrock taii along with the sapphire
pure and Nitro plus were all virtually
silent generating less noise than our
case fans the XFX Mercury was also very
quiet and could only just be heard over
the case fans while the Asus tough
gaming was noticeably audible but still
reasonably quiet as for core clock
speeds all models were much the same
with no more than a 3% variance out of
the box so there shouldn't be too much
performance difference between these
various models so that's all the aib
cards we have on hand for the moment for
now I think we should move on and get
into the blue bar
graphs first up we have Marvel Rivals at
1440p and here the 970 XT was good for
88 FPS on average though that did make
it 7% slower than the 5070 TI and just
6% faster than the 7900 XT so not bad
but also not an amazing start then at 4K
it's slips a little further behind the
5070 TI now trailing by an 11% margin
with 51 FPS on average moving on to
stalker 2 again at 1440p the 9070 XT is
coming in slower than the 5070 TI this
time trailing by a 9% margin which
actually made it 2% slower than the 7900
XT so that's a disappointing result
bumping the resolution up to 4K did help
and now it's just 5% slower than the 572
and 5% faster than the 7900 XT still not
an amazing result but probably good
enough despite only rendering 39 FPS on
average this time we see when testing
with counter- strike 2 that the 9070 XT
is coming in 10% slower than the 5070 TI
which is quite a significant margin in
fact here it only managed to match the
7900 gr this is a very weak result and
sadly this isn't a game AMD benchmarked
for their review guide so I'm not sure
if they're also seeing the same poor
performance or they would if they tested
it it's also quite surprising that
they're not actually testing the most
popular game on Steam and things only
got worse at 4K here the new radi on GPU
trailed the 5070 TI by a 16% margin only
roughly matching the RTX
5070 finally we have a game in godvore
Ragnarok where the 9070 XT is able to
match the 70 TI and I wouldn't say it
necessarily won at 1440p given it was a
mere 1% faster but seeing RTX 4080 light
performance was impressive the 4K
margins are really much the same here
the 970 XT was just 1% slower than the
570 ti so again it was able to deliver
7900 XTX and RTX 480 like performance so
that's very good the Delta Force
performance wasn't great here the 970 XT
averaged 60 FPS which is you know
certainly great performance but that
result meant it was 8% slower than the
5070 TI and 10% slower than the 7900 XT
so I'm not sure what went wrong there to
see it deliver 4070 super light
performance the 4K results were a lot
better though here it matched the 7900
XT so still not an amazing result in on
itself and that did make it 6% slower
than the 5070 ti so overall not a
particularly great game for the new new
rad on
GPU now the 970 XT was excellent in
Space Marine 2 beating even the 7900 XTX
also please note that the Blackwell
results aren't wrong for whatever reason
the new GeForce 50 Series performs very
poorly in this game and so far Nvidia
hasn't been able to address this so as a
result the 970 XT is 177% faster than
the 5070 TI at
1440p and then at 4K it ends up being a
massive 36% faster and again I really
don't know what's wrong here with the
GeForce 50 Series I actually ended up
throwing my results out and retesting
this entire game for all gpus due to a
recent update where I thought it changed
performance but really the performance
for most of the gpus is much the same
it's just the Blackwell gpus that appear
broken Nvidia really does need to
address this Star Wars Jedi Survivor has
another example for us where the 970 XT
is actually slower than the 79 900 XT at
1440p albe it by Just 2 FPS but perhaps
more importantly that meant it was 12%
slower than the 5070 TI and that margin
does shrink slightly to 8% at 4K but
even so just 53 FPS on average means
that the 970 XT was only slightly faster
than the 4070 TI super and 7900
XT the 970 XT performs well in a play
toale reum coming in just behind the 70
900 XTX at 1440p though that did make it
7% slower than the 5070 TI but I think
overall that is a solid result now at 4K
the 970 XT is 4% slower than the 572
with 65 FPS on average so the same level
of performance seen from the RTX 480 and
I think that's quite
impressive now the radon gpus have
always performed well in cyberpunk 2077
and the 970 XT thankfully is no
exception rendering 125 FPS at 1440p
allowing it to match the 5070 TI and
that also made it 11% faster than the
7900 XT then at 4K it pulled slightly
ahead of the 5070 TI albeit by a mere 3%
margin but that meant that it was now
177% faster than the 7900 XT so a great
result
overall unfortunately though the 970 XT
struggled quite a bit in Dying Light too
only just beating the oldest 7900 XT
which saw it come in 12% slower than the
5070 TI and the 4K data is much the same
here the 970 XT was again 12% slower
than the 570 TI though it was also 12%
faster than the 7900
XT Call of Duty has always been a
positive title for AMD and Black Ops 6
is no exception here the 97t XT spat out
an impressive 118 FPS at 1440p allowing
to roughly the 7900 XTX and this s it
beat the 507 TI by an impressive 22%
margin then at 4K it led the 5070 TI by
a 19% margin again delivering 7900 XTX
like performance so another excellent
result here for the new 970
XT next up we have Dragon Age the
valgard and this game does use some Raad
tracing with the ultra preset but even
so the 970 XT still performed okay
coming in 4% slower than the 57 ETI
though really we're only looking at
roughly 7900 XT performance in this
example now at 4K the 970 XT matched the
4070 TI super making it 10% faster than
the 7900 XT but also 10% slower than the
TI unfortunately radon gpus perform
quite poorly relative to the GeForce
competition in War Thunder when using
the default direct X11 mode the 97 7 XT
was only able to match the 7900 XT
making it a massive 31% slower than the
5072 at
1440p however when we increase the
resolution to 4K things change quite
dramatically and now the 9070 XT is very
impressive matching the 7900 XTX and 570
TI with 227
FPS the Spider-Man remaster performance
is pretty disappointing at 1440p the 90
70 XT ended up slower than the 7900 XT
and that saw it Trail the 5070 TI by an
8% margin but as we often see the 4K
data is more positive and here it
matched the 57 e2i with 118 FPS the
Hogwarts Legacy performance looks
promising though that is Until you
realize that despite being 4% faster
than the 5072 1440p the 970 XT is still
slower than both the 9700 XT and XTX
that does all change though at 4K and
here the 970 XT managed to outperform
not just the 572 I but also the 7900 XTX
with an impressive 87 FPS on
average the 970 XT was 5% slower than
the 5070 TI in The Last of Us Part One
rendering 106 FPS on average which
actually made it a few frames slower
than the 7900 XT then at 4K it was 3%
slower than the 570 TI though it was at
least 9% faster than the 7900
XT performance in Star Wars Outlaws was
decent here the 970 XT was just 5%
slower than the 57 1440p but 13% faster
than the 7900 XT then at 4K it basically
matched the 570 TI and 7900 XTX which
meant it was now 21% faster than the
7900 XT finally we have Starfield and
here the 970 XT was 7% slower than the
570 1440p as it only delivered 7900 XT
light performance the 4K data was more
favorable but even so it was only able
to roughly match the 5070 TI while just
edging out the likes of nvidia's RTX 470
TI
super okay so across the 18 games that I
use for testing the 9070 XT averaged 119
FPS at 1440 P which made it 6% slower
than the 5070 TI and I believe AMD were
expecting to see parody there it's not
far off mind you but the rad on GPU was
slower overall perhaps more troubling
though is the fact that AMD claimed the
970 XT was on average 37% faster than
the 7900 GRE for rter performance but we
found just a 20% Improvement when
looking at mostly rter
performance and just as troubling is the
fact that the 970 XT is just 2% faster
than the 7900 XT and 133% slower than
the 7900
XTX now at 4K the 97t XT does look a bit
better coming in just 1% slower than the
5070 TI and 9% faster than the 7900 XT
not exactly amazing performance overall
but at $600 it could end up being
something pretty special and we'll look
at that in a moment now when it comes to
power consumption the 9070 XT it isn't
exactly amazing but it's also not bad
when compared to rdna A3 little is
changed as we just saw you're roughly
getting 7900 XT performance for roughly
7900 XT power consumption so we're often
looking at around 20% more power usage
than the 5070 TI for slightly weaker
performance so when it comes to R
tracing performance the 97 txt is
generally much better than rdna 3 and we
see this when comparing with parts such
as the 17900 XT and even the XTX in
Metro Exodus at 144p the 970 XT was 9%
slower than the 5070 TI but it was also
34% faster than the 7900 XT and 12%
faster than the
XTX then at 4K it trailed the 570 TI by
a 12% margin and was 18% faster than the
7900 XTX and a whopping 44% faster than
the 7900
XT the alwe 2 performance though it's
not good but also it's the first ever
radon GPU that will have for over 30 FPS
at 1440p with upscaling when using the
high rate tracing settings so I guess
that's something it's also a massive 44%
performance uplift Wing compared to the
7900 XTX but despite that it is still
36% slower than the 5070
TI then at 4K the demands are obviously
too EXT stream and even here the 5072 is
only able to average 31
FPS now the cyberpunk 277 Ultra rad
tracing performance is quite impressive
from the 97 txt at 1440p using upscaling
it managed to render 68 FPS making it
just 8% slower than the 570 TI which is
an incredible result for a radon GPU and
that meant it was 24% faster than the
7900 XTX and 51% FAS faster than the
XT as expected though it did struggle at
4K when using upscaling but even so the
970 XT was 12% slower than the 570 TI
and then 29% faster than the 7900
XTX despite running into a CPU
bottleneck in Spider-Man remastered the
970 XT was still 22% faster than the
7900 XTX at
1440p then jumping up to 4K sees the 970
XT trailing the 570 TI by just 7% though
this also meant the new radon GPU was a
few frames slower than the
XTX next up we have Dying Light 2 and
here the 970 XT was 14% slower than the
570 TI at 1440p making it slightly
faster than the 7900 XTX which is
another great result then at 4K it again
just managed to Edge out the XTX coming
in 29% slower than the 5070 TI
black myth Wukong still isn't too kind
to the radon GPU the 970 XT rendered
just 30 FPS at 1440p which is an almost
60% Boost from the XTX but also roughly
half the performance of the 5070 TI that
being the case we don't really need to
talk about the 4K results but here they
are
anyway finally we have Indiana Jones in
the great circle and this was a great
cluster for the 970 XT just 17 FP s on
average at 1440p with
upscaling of course I also ran the
numbers at 4K but again as you can see
you can just ignore this data as none of
these gpus are able to deliver playable
performance or at least what we would
call playable performance under these
conditions okay so here's a look at the
average rate tracing performance seen at
1440p when generally using upscaling and
here the 970 XT was 21% slower than the
570 TI but an impressive 26% faster than
the 7900 XTX so with rdna A4 AMD has
made huge strides when it comes to RT
performance now a lot of the 4K data was
a bust for the 9070 XT though for quite
a few titles the 5072 was also extremely
slow even so we have the data and here
the 970 XT was on average 25% slower
than the 5070
TI now it's time for the all important
cost per frame analysis and we'll start
with the elus MSRP so the fake MSRP data
if you will at least when it comes to
nvidia's Blackwell gpus if the 5072 was
readily available at $750 us which it
currently isn't the 970 XT is only
offering 15% better value which is
reasonable but in the past we felt AMD
needs to offer 20% better value for a
solid review
recommendation of course with rdna A4
we're now getting better rate tracing
performance and FSR for which we're in
the process of analyzing and we'll have
a dedicated and highly detailed video
for you
shortly so perhaps we're at a point
where 15% better value can result in a
review recommendation in fact I'm pretty
confident it can now but I'll talk more
about this in a moment for now let's
look at what is considered to be the
real
MSRP as it stands if AMD can deliver the
970 XT for $600 us and we've been
reliably informed by multiple sources
that they can and will then as things
stand right now the 9070 XT will be
delivering 29% better value than the
5070 TI and this is key because we
believe based on sales data evidence
that AMD needs to deliver 30% greater
value than their nearest GeForce
competitor in order to convert GeForce
owners to becoming radon
owners now if we compare the 970 XT to
the best retail prices from mid 2020 4
it still looks very good delivering
nearly 20% better value than the
discounted 7900 XT amd's best value
offering in this performance range it's
also 26% better value than the 4070 TI
super so there you have it the new radon
RX 970 XT and I've got to admit this is
a difficult one to sum up on one hand I
know there's going to be some people who
are quite disappointed with the
performance they've seen here even when
keeping the price in mind and maybe
that's on AMD and their performance
claims which I'll get to soon but I
think overall what's on offer here in
the current market is very good and
worthy of
recommendation there's really two main
conclusions that you can make here one
being if the 570 TI stays well above
MSRP so typically around
$900 along with the poor availability
then at $600 us the 970 XT is going to
be a no-brainer it's offering almost 30%
better value you would be mad not to buy
it but the other conclusion being if the
5070 TI manages to drop down to the MSRP
then the 9070 XT becomes 20% cheaper to
purchase and in terms of cost per frame
it's just 15% better value it's a little
over 20% slower on average for rracing
and then you have to weigh up the other
features which we're in the process of
doing some of that I certainly think
saving $150 US by going with the 970 XT
is going to be a good idea for most
Gamers but whether or not AMD can
convince most Gamers of this well that's
an entirely different story and historic
data would suggest that this isn't
enough to convert GeForce owners it's
also worth noting that although I've
closely compared the 970 xt's
performance with the 5070 TI in terms of
pricing it's actually much closer to the
standard RTX
5070 the thing is though the rtx550 70
sucks it's a poor value option with just
12 GB of vram So based on that fact
alone I don't recommend it and therefore
comparing the 9070 XT to a GPU we
already don't recommend seems like a
waste of time and not really a great win
for the new 970 XT also just another
side note for the radon 7000 versus
GeForce 40 series Tim and myself agreed
that AMD needed to offer at least 20%
better cost per frame value in order for
us to recommend Radeon gpus but with the
Radeon 9000 versus GeForce 50 Series we
feel this does need to be revised
downwards probably to 15% and this is
due to the improved rate tracing
performance and the fact that amd's
upscaling technology has improved
dramatically and should close the gap to
dlss though we are still busy
investigating if that is indeed the case
so it's a little too early to call right
now but what we can say is FSR 4 is
world's better than FSR 3 so all of this
certainly does help the 9070 XT at least
in our eyes but what Gamers at large
think could be a different story and
therefore AMD might still need to be
targeting a 30% discount again to
convert those GeForce owners but what
all this means is in a world where the
9070 XT can be purchased for $600 and
the 5070 TI
$750 it's difficult to recommend one
over the other there's pros and cons to
either Choice which is why we felt for
AMD to really Crush nvidia's mid-range
this generation the 9070 XT would have
to hit $550 us but if supply of the 5070
TI remains weak and therefore prices Sky
High the 970 XT should win anyway so in
short we feel if AMD can maintain a 20%
margin to the 5070 TI as in 20% better
cost per frame than the 970 txt will be
the obvious choice in our opinion no
need to toss up between the two just get
the rad on GPU for that nice discount
now to change gears for a moment I'm a
bit concerned that AMD has managed to
once again set the wrong expectations
this time of course for the 970 XT by
comparing it to the gr and then quoting
what looks to be heavily inflated
numbers at least when compared to our
own independent
testing AMD claimed that the 970 XT was
an average 35 5% faster than the GRE for
raster performance at 1440p but in
reality we found it to be just 20%
faster different sample of games of
course but some examples AMD claimed a
39% Improvement in Dragon Age but I only
got 25% then 32% in Starfield but I only
saw 20% and 29% better performance in
stalker whereas I only saw 16% better
performance so perhaps in the games
without built-in benchmarks AMD is
testing in an area with a lighter load
I'm not really sure how the numbers
differ so much but in reality amd's
numbers make the J appear much slower
than it really is or of course the 9070
XT much faster than it really is the
fact is a 35% boost over the jar would
make the 970 XT as fast as the 7900 XTX
and 480 super based on our data and I
did see many people claiming that would
indeed be the case based on amd's first
party Benchmark result results We
Believe AMD was set to charge at least
$650 us for the 9070 XT and they were
under the impression that that would be
a great price and this would make sense
if it really was 35% FAS than the gr and
able to match or even beat the 5070 ti
so like what we saw with the release of
the ryzen 7
9700x not really sure how AMD is doing
their internal
testing okay so I'm going to stand for
this bit because I'm not really sure how
real the $600 us MSRP is and this is
because I've done some digging around
and it sounds like while there will be
some stock available at the
MSRP in order to achieve this AMD is
providing retailers a $50 US rebate this
is sort of a temporary thing or it could
be and this suggests that the price was
intended to be at least $650 us that's
ultimately what AMD want for this
product but at least for now AMD are
subsidizing some models so they can hit
that $600 us MSR P but it's going to be
I imagine in limited numbers XFX for
example have told me that the 970
Mercury the model we featured in this
video this guy right
here this one won't be selling at the
$650 us MSRP what even cost $700 rather
the actual MSRP from XFX for this one is
a whopping
$770 us and on shelf pricing for the us
because of tariffs and all that fun
stuff
it's expected to be $850 us so that's a
bit tragic if true now based on the
information I have been out of gather it
does sound as though AMD is starting to
play the game that is of course nvidia's
game so this means the $600 us MSRP
might not really be a thing Beyond sort
of the initial very limited supply of
MSRP models but that leaves everything
else well above $600 and restocks of
those
MSRP models let's say are expected to be
few and far between so I think how this
is going to ultimately play out will
depend on how sales go AMD does have a
lot of 9070 series stock so if sales are
slow after the initial demand then I'm
sure they will keep those rebates going
but of course we'll just have to wait
and see how that one plays out anyway as
things stand no pun intended the radon
RX 970 XT is a great offering that we
expect will sell extremely well at
$600 but hitting that price is certainly
in question at this point in time so
again we have to see how that one plays
out before I suppose ultimately making
our decision on how successful this
product has been but yeah at the $600 if
they can do that it's good and if they
do manage to sell out so if the pricing
is good and aimd sell all of the stock
that they have what that means is they
will have sold considerably more 9070
XTS that Nvidia has 509s 80s 507s and
5070 TI combined so that's pretty crazy
and on that bombshell I'm going to end
this video if you liked it give it a
thumbs up we have the 970 reviews the
non XT model coming tomorrow and
hopefully we'll have a bit more pricing
information and have a bit more insight
into how things are playing out uh by
the time that video goes live uh we also
have the join button patreon if you want
to become a member you get access to our
exclusive Discord server monthly live
streams Q&A stuff and behind the scenes
content so check that out if you're
interested but if not that's perfectly
fine and I would like to thank you for
watching this video I'm your host Steve
see you again next time
[Music]